The joe rogan experience.
My daughter Loves Bible stories.
Really?
I'm an atheist.
You say once upon a time
before you tell them,
oh,
I know.
She knows that stories.
Okay,
yeah.
We call him the big invisible guy,
and you go old school,
Old Testament,
or do you go,
we'd do the whole thing.
Oh yeah.
I've told her the story of,
you know,
I'm the guy who's going to kill his
son because the big invisible guy,
I say,
making them in an ice cream,
like baking a pie with whipped
cream because you know it's,
that's why you surfing.
I don't have a knife to the throat.
I mean,
she's,
she was four,
but she loves the big
invisible guy stories.
She loves the Noah one.
She loves the Adam and Eve one
with the snake and the apple.
It's all,
I mean,
these stories that they've
stood the test of time.
There's really some of the best stories
around who was going to kill his,
his son was Cain and Abel.
Now Cain and Abel,
where the son of Adam and eve,
they were brothers and
they killed each other.
Right.
I said,
Isaac and Abraham,
Isaac and I go know,
can we have a weapon?
Abraham Abraham was so,
and God is asking him
to kill us on for him.
Yeah.
You know,
as I love test.
Yeah.
Just because you know,
that's how,
you know,
if someone really loves you,
like,
you know,
this is why,
you give this,
um,
you give this to your,
to your wife,
you know,
like I would,
I would murder our offspring for you.
And that's the hallmark card that really
helps your wife understand how much you
love her.
I'm just an ex boyfriend.
I'm earning export,
export from the beat you up.
I'll murder him.
And so,
but,
and I'm trying to tell the
stories in a neutral way,
right?
Like it's like,
again,
I had my opinions on all
these stories and all that,
but she really likes the stories
and she's a huge fan of Lucifer.
Whoa.
I mean,
Lucifer is the guy,
he is like her superhero,
you know,
like he is her mighty
morphin power rangers.
She thinks he is just the coolest cause
he's always standing up to big invisible
guy.
Right.
And,
um,
because for her prayer is,
you know,
everyone's standing around and say,
Oh,
you the best.
Oh you're the best.
Oh you're the greatest.
I love you so much.
Oh you're the best.
You know.
And so,
you know,
Lucifer gets kind of tired of that
and leads the rebellion and all that.
Cause you know,
I said,
you know,
just keep saying it.
And she said,
I'm getting tired of it.
It's like,
no,
I keep saying it because it's an
eternity of saying that to the gate.
Right?
And she's like,
Oh man,
I'm really tired.
I want to sit down.
It's like now you know
how Lucifer out of it.
Anyway,
so she's got this great,
she's just great song,
which goes basically,
Lucifer was raw hide.
Lucifer was right.
You know,
why the songs,
and I'm just waiting.
Cause you know,
in Canada there's some homeschooling,
which is kind of and
schooling what we were doing,
but a lot of them are,
are Christians,
right?
So we're going to at some point be around
a bunch of Christian kids and she's
going to break into this song.
And I'm looking forward to that moment of,
I've tried to explain that,
uh,
maybe she's referring to a Beatles song.
I don't know how I completely
bailed on her at that point.
I don't know where she gets us.
Well,
the real issue is you're going to have
to mingle with those Christian parents.
The real issue when you have children,
uh,
besides raising the children,
which is of course the primary one,
teaching them and everything is dealing
with these other parents and seeing
it's,
it's really weird when I
see people with their kids,
you know,
see how little they
interact with their kids,
see how like non appreciative
they are of their kids,
how they're always distracted or the ring
of cell phones around the playground,
you know,
like it to throw your cell phone,
go play,
go into stupid Mcdonald's tubes
and go play with your kids.
I know a woman who's a psychologist and
she picks up her kid and she's on her
phone while she's picking the kid up,
the kid trying to talk to her
about school and she's like,
uh Huh.
Uh Huh.
And she's texting.
It's,
you know,
I mean you just,
the kid was gone for five hours and
when you pick them up you're texting.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
so,
it's so attractive to us though.
So easy to do.
It's so easy to ignore.
We get so used to,
you know,
the kid being around and we get
so used to our own free time.
Oh my daughter's really good at that.
Sorry to drive it.
She's great.
Cause you know,
like I'm trying to teach your eye contact,
right?
Because you know,
when she's a kid,
you know,
I don't know if they can't
focus when they look at you,
but that tell stories like they're just
watching the biggest disco light show on
the planet and you're just
like some leaf or something.
Right.
And so I tried to remind her,
you know,
eye contact number,
talking,
that kind of stuff.
Right.
So the other day of course,
and I,
you know,
I try,
Oh gel,
you know,
and I,
but every now and then
like I get donations,
my whole show is just donations,
right.
No ads or anything.
And so,
you know,
when a donation comes in it's like,
Ooh,
kibble.
You know,
like I'm,
I'm like the wrap with the pellet,
you know that people,
what did they get?
And I got this little kitchen noise
that comes in cause I'm for anyway,
so you know,
the kitchen noise come in.
My daughter was telling me something
really important for her and all that and,
and yeah,
she's great.
She's like four,
she's like,
Daddy,
I can't act like you're absolutely right.
I'm so sorry.
How rude that was of me.
I apologize.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's fascinating to watch
their little brains develop,
isn't it?
Then watch the way they interacted each
other and how they see the world and
realize like that this is
how a person is shaped.
And this is the number one problem
that we have as a race is that we don't
respect this process and that we also
don't respect this process in strangers.
Especially people that we know are fucked.
People in bad neighborhoods,
people in bad circumstances,
people in a abusive families.
We know they're fucked and we don't,
we don't do anything to stop it.
One thing that I keep harping on
is that if we have a resource,
whether it's oil or gold bean,
we protect that resource and,
and you know we,
we set up laws and we
attach a value to it,
but our number one resource
for sure is human beings.
We have created all that you see,
whether it's laptops or buildings or cars,
that's all from a human being.
The best way to ensure that that continues
to go on is to have less losers in
the world.
The best way to have less
losers is help out kids,
educate kids,
get on the ball with them very early
and do something as a society to protect
them primary before we go into wars,
before we go into all this stupid shit
that we do to spying on people's fucking
emails and looking into
their cell phone record.
Before you do any of that,
how about you protect kids first?
That should be of primary importance and
it should be like one of those things
where your kid,
you know,
wants to go out and play.
Like do have you done your homework?
You haven't done your homework,
you can't play.
It's that fucking simple.
You can't have your wars
unless you fixed the kids.
Okay.
Well,
and they're,
they're so smart.
And I,
you know,
I was,
the humans had a whole bunch of experts,
a on my show,
uh,
which is who talk about
the native intelligence of,
of kids.
Like kids can start doing mathematical
reasoning at seven or eight months of
age.
They can start,
do using empathy at 14 months.
And my daughter at the age of,
uh,
a four,
we started playing a game called
subjective versus objective.
You know,
like is this something subjective?
Like I like ice cream or is this something
objective like ice cream is made from
milk.
And you know,
we'd pointed staff as they subject.
There were objective,
you know,
I liked jazz,
subjective or objective and she's like,
Bang,
rattling them off.
The other day she was saying to me,
dad,
you know,
we've talked a lot.
She's always asking me about the show.
In fact,
I should've been taking notes
because she's asked me all about you,
uh,
what's going to be the topic?
And I said,
you know what,
I have no idea.
I know it's gonna be
interesting to chat with Joe,
no idea what we're going to talk about.
And that was the best conversation.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's asked all about,
you know,
where you're from and what
you do and she's awesome.
They did buy mixed martial arts
and all that kind of stuff.
And uh,
um,
and so she's going to ask me all the
time and I do some shows on economics and
so we talked a little bit about that,
you know,
get money and all that.
And I diagram stuff out for her to,
and she gets it really.
We've gone through the whole history
of the Second World War the other day.
She says,
you know,
my Daddy,
I think I've decided why I want to do,
I think when I get bigger,
I think I just like to work at it.
I want to be the government.
I'd love to be the
government because I just,
I want to type whatever I
wanted to my bank account.
And I was just like,
wow,
you just nailed the Federal Reserve.
Like right there in a nutshell,
whatever I want into my bank account.
[inaudible] your old logic but perfect.
That is what it is.
They can print their own money.
Yeah.
It's beautiful.
Great system.
Yeah.
No and I and I,
I come out of the sort
of libertarian world,
right?
So I mean I'm an anarchist but I
come out of the libertarian world and
Libertarians very much as we talked
about non aggression principle and so on,
and I've been fighting this,
this battle in the libertarian world
and in other worlds as well around,
you know,
things is to me is basic a spanking,
right?
I wasn't sure,
I mean we touched on this,
we
just throw a few stats for the
audience who hasn't seen it before.
More than 90% of parents of toddlers
say they smacked their child.
Toddlers,
60 61% of moms,
three to five year olds
have spank their child.
In the past week.
Boys is spanked a lot more than girls.
Boys are also diagnosed with Adhd,
which is one of the symptoms of
spanking a lot more than girls.
Spanking can continue
into the adolescent years.
30 to 40% of people in junior high,
kids in junior high.
I still being spanked.
Moms do spank children a
lot more than fathers do.
Even controlling for time spent with
kids and all of that kind of stuff.
Uh,
economic status doesn't have a
huge amount to do with spanking,
but culture does.
So African Americans a do a do
a lot more corporate punishment.
Uh,
religious conservative fundamentalists
do a lot more corporal punishment and so
on.
And this to me is such
a fundamental thing.
I'm very much for philosophy
that you can do philosophy,
that you can act on
values that you can do.
Yeah,
I don't like the Federal Reserve.
I think central banking is a monstrous
cancer in the eyeball of society,
but I can't really do much about it
other than rant and rave about it.
But we kept,
what we can do is,
you know,
do some basics like stop hitting kids.
You know,
that to me it's a very fundamental,
and in the libertarian community
that's a challenge lot.
A lot of um,
religious conservatives in the
libertarian community as you know,
like on the,
on the right or wrong republicans,
there tend to be more
religious people on the left,
a secularist less religious people
but more socialists and so on.
And it is really tough,
you know,
to just get that basic thing across.
We tell kids not to hit each other
and we hit kids and we've all,
I don't know if you out there,
you see bad parenting sometimes
when you're out and you act,
you actually,
and I'll usually say something to
the parents because I don't mind my,
my Aa,
I think it's the right thing to do.
I don't want my daughter to see me be
all about the ethics and then not talk to
people doing something wrong.
But you can see parents hit kids
saying don't hit your sister.
And that the fact that they can do that
without their heads exploding from this
wormhole contradiction of
Pretzel logic is just astounding.
But it is something,
we still have a long way to go in.
I think we're kind of
slowly getting there,
but we have a long way to go
and just let's not hit kids.
Yeah.
I think how much of the world
would change if we didn't do that?
I think we would be virtually
unrecognizable as a culture.
I couldn't agree more.
You know,
I read this article recently
on my message board.
Uh,
I don't have it in front of me,
so I apologize to whoever posted it,
but it was about a man who got stuck in
the financial system of divorce and it
was from his perspective,
he committed suicide,
lit himself on fire.
I started reading his perspective and
they came to his house and he had his
initial issue because he slapped his
daughter in the mouse so hard that her
mouth was bleeding.
And he did it because
she was licking his hand.
She kept licking his hands,
so he slapped her in the mouth til
her mouth was and then everything I,
I,
I stopped reading right there.
I'm like,
I don't want to know this guy.
I don't,
I,
I'm sad that he was so fucked
up that he committed suicide.
But if I saw a guy slap his daughter
in the face because she was,
you know,
was licking his hand,
I would have to really suppress
my urge to strangle him.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's violence.
That's violence to someone who
cannot defend themselves leaf.
Not only that,
not only that,
it's,
it's fundamentally the most fucked up
kind of violence because you're doing it
to a developing human being
who you allegedly love.
You're teaching them the violence is
a part of life by the people that they
respect the most and that it can be done
to you at any time when you don't agree
with whatever fucking guidelines
and rules they've set up,
like licking your hand.
And my daughter was licking my hand.
I'd be laughing my ass off.
I would think.
It's so funny I do that.
I'd smack her in the mouth.
It just fucking insane.
But people,
they fall into this pattern
and they don't know.
Don't realize that violence is violence
just because you're not going to hurt
the kid that bad.
They're just going to spank him
and you think it's no big deal.
Fuck yeah,
it's a big deal because that kid,
it's a horrific situation.
You're doing something
that they can't control.
Your holding their arm,
they're moving their body and then this
big hand comes in slaps their ass and
they feel pain and they feel confused
cause you've acted out against them.
You've not only acted out against him,
you've done it aggressively yelling
at slapping and it's a terrible,
it's terrible precedent to set a terrible
idea to plant in a child's mind and
it's unnecessary.
It's just not necessary for you to tell
me that you can't sit down and reason
with your child and do
it with love and the,
yeah,
they're going to freak
out and fucking flail.
Sometimes they get mad and yell and
that's because they're a fucking child.
You piece of Shit,
you don't smack them.
You know,
you just need someone for being short,
pitting your friends.
It's like hitting your for I don't be,
don't hit anybody man.
Well,
and,
and in particular,
you know,
the moral concentration of
like black hearted nastiness,
you know,
you hit your wife,
she,
she got to date you.
She got to,
you know,
you had an engagement.
She,
you know,
she,
she chose you and you chose her,
but if you hit your wife,
she at least had to do you
get to test drive you shit,
you know,
and then she can leave at anytime.
She's an adult,
she's got shelters,
she's got whatever.
People will help her,
hopefully.
But kids that didn't
choose you as parents,
you know,
and they can't leave and
they have no options.
And I say this,
my daughter,
you know,
I say,
um,
I know you're not here by choice.
You know,
you didn't choose me as the
day I choose to have kids.
I didn't,
you didn't choose me as a dad.
The way I have to parent
is I want to parent.
Like,
if my daughter did have a choice of any
doubt in the world that she would choose
me like,
and so I imagine these all day long.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and what about feedback?
You know,
and I go to my local pizza joint
half the time I have to fill out.
Why don't they give me this
comment card to fill out,
you know,
how did you like the pizza,
it good for you or was it bad for you?
You know,
they wanna know they wanna have good
pizza and how many times the parents do
that with their kids say,
how am I doing,
you know,
how's your experience of my parenting?
You know,
what's more important slice of pizza or
your relationship with your offspring.
You know,
ask them how you're doing.
How could they have been better?
What did I do that,
that you liked?
What did I do that you didn't like?
And all that.
Get that kind of feedback.
I don't know.
It's just weird that we don't
even think of doing that.
Well,
I think your perspective is very unique
in the fact that you are a stay at home
dad and you do have the
resources to be able to do that.
It's,
it's,
it's really hard for a lot of people.
And that's while you were
talking about before,
that number's pretty crazy.
The 20 minutes a week.
I didn't know that it was that low,
but honestly,
not shocked.
I don't have a regular life,
but I've dabbled in regular life,
you know,
I've had like jobs that take me away
for a long period of time during the day
and I could only imagine what kind of
energy you have to devote to a kid.
If the mother,
both the mother and the father
both leave the house all day long,
work an eight hour day and then come home.
How much is left?
There's not even much time
the kid's going to be awake.
Yeah.
How much energy do you have left?
How much focus or you're putting
on that kid during the day
and,
and we have this,
I'll get a couple more stats.
Um,
we have this idea that the moms have
to be there and the dads can be there.
But a study conducted by Dr. Kyle Pruitt
found that infants between seven and 30
months respond more favorably to
being picked up by their fathers.
He also found a father's parenting style
is beneficial for a child's physical,
cognitive and emotional
and behavioral development.
Mothers tend to reassure toddlers when
they become frustrated while fathers
encouraged them to
manage their frustration.
And my daughter's like this,
so she's learning to do
all these things and,
and most of her friends
are older cause you know,
we're not the youngest on the block.
And so a lot of her friends can
do stuff better than she can.
She gets frustrated and me helping her
talk it through that frustration and
reminding her that I didn't know
how to do this stuff and you know,
she's trying to do racket sports and I
remember took me years to become good at
racket sports.
So,
uh,
so that's important for,
for kids as well.
I mean,
it's really important to remember,
you know,
the,
the mom and the kid,
they used to be the same freaking person,
you know,
like she grew her,
they were like this,
it's like my arm,
you know,
it's not like a separate thing.
Whereas they had to have a little
bit more objectivity around that.
A longer term study that this guy
did to prove that a father's active
involvement with his kids from birth to
adolescence promotes greater emotional
balance,
stronger curiosity,
a stronger sense of self assurance,
additional studies during the
first five years of a child's life.
The father's role is more influential
than the mothers in how the child learns
to manage his or her body,
navigate social,
social,
social circumstances in play.
And the last one is this.
The 1996 study that I was referring
to before by Mcgill University.
Uh,
the single most important childhood
factor in developing empathy is paternal
involvement in childcare.
The study further concluded that children
who spend time alone binding but the
children more than twice per week
brought up the most compassionate adults.
Um,
so
how do they measure that?
How's that quantifiable?
Um,
it seems like a weird,
all of those statistics seemed very odd.
It's like how do you know what caused
the person to have more empathy?
How do you know what caused the
person to be able to move better?
And I mean,
how do you,
how do you work
well,
what they proved that,
again,
it's sort of a many to many relationships.
So they asked the father is,
you know,
how often were you involved in,
maybe they even measured them if it's
sort of a life study and then they
measured the compassion and then they
measure a whole bunch of other things.
And if the other things don't
change the compassion measure,
but then the parental involvement
is what moves the needle,
then they assume that
that's close to causal.
But isn't the issue also
the parental involvement?
Like say if a father is involved
a lot in the kid's life,
he's also probably likely involved in
the relationship with the wife and maybe
their wife would be more happy.
The father and the wife would be more
happy and because of that they would both
be better parents.
So it could,
it might not just be that the impact
of having a man around does all these
things and creates an empathy.
It might be the impact of having
a successful family as well.
Right,
right.
And that certainly is true.
And again,
I didn't run the studies.
I assume that they've tried,
like whenever you question this,
always tried to tease it
out this way or that way,
and they,
they to try to find that answer.
Um,
but I do think that compassion,
again,
you know,
I mean,
you,
your marriage,
you've got,
you've got kids floating around
and all that and floating,
but there,
but they were floating at one point and
then they came out through the magic
chamber.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think,
you know,
I mean,
my wife's skills as a
parent are fantastic and,
um,
but,
but there are some differences between us,
you know,
and I don't know whether it's biological
or whether it's just the way we were
raised or whatever,
but,
uh,
you know,
I encourage more risk taking a,
I'm,
I encourage,
you know,
if you fall off the horse,
get back up and again,
kind of stuff.
And I think that's just sort of,
kind of a natural kind of difference.
And,
um,
I'm also more encouraging of,
you know,
my daughter is like crazy frenzy.
I keep thinking she's going to go up to
someone sometimes an unfriendly world,
like a cheese up to a greater,
you know,
we're just kind of get shredded because,
we go places and she just
goes up to kids and says,
hi,
would you like to be friends?
And I was cool.
Fantastic.
You know,
the old people up a little,
you know,
oh,
I love it.
Wouldn't that be,
everybody was on ecstasy.
That's how we would
interact with each other.
Okay.